Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
Marvel released a new Spider-Man No Way Home
I Max trailer with some extra details in the
footage we didn't see in the previous trailer
is been all kinds of new Tobey Maguire Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man details that of come out
so if it is a great time to do new Easter
eggs video.
If you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's gonna be a lot
of Spider-Man related stuff happening in the
next six months or so between all the different
Spider-Man movies are coming out.
But you will probably watch the Spider-Man
No Way Home trailer a billion times.
There's some really obvious Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield references
in the trailer and some hidden details and
references to some of the scenes marvel and
Sony chopped up in the trailer to hide was
actually going on in some of the scenes are
just so darkly lit that you need to crank
up the brightness all the way up to 100 just
to see the background details like inside
the basement of the sanctum were kind of seems
like Doctor Strange is keeping sinister six
characters from the multiverse prisoner like
some kind of crazy magical Guant\'e1namo Bay
also thinks that this new IMAX version of
the trailer with the expanded footage and
details that we get you can actually see this
person here is not Matt Murdock daredevil
character Charlie Cox is like see you can
clearly see these are not my forearms in the
previous trailer a lot of people just theorized
that maybe Matt Murdock helps them out at
some point during one of these scenes is possible
that he still in the movie somewhere just
not in this particular scene, but will start
with a bigger more obvious Easter eggs and
references then talk about the newer hidden
details that we got in some more information
about recently.
Yes I know that everyone is still talking
about this special-effects scene of Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man the people claim is from
the movie.
Apparently there was a deep fake artist that
use the picture of this the Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man blue screen and animated it then
in mid that was fake.
But then supposedly recanted that pardon said
that it wasn't fake.
Like the picture itself that he used to make
the deep fake animation was not fake just
the animation so I wouldn't worry too much
about that.
The reason why it doesn't matter whether or
not this scene is real or not.
Is because the whole point is that we all
believe that Andrew Garfield is in the movie,
so they the take away from this particular
scene here is your who cares it might not
be a scene in the movie.
But Andrew Garfield Spider-Man is in the movie
also if there were actual like really big
leaks like this Sony would've taken them down
for copyright immediately when they first
happen.
They have an army of people dedicated to protecting
against huge leaks like this if you remember
when avengers endgame leaked out on YouTube
the week before the movie came out marvel
full lipped but in the trailer.
We can clearly see at least five of the original
core sinister six characters is the very obvious
Alfred Molina Doctor octopus because he literally
steps out on this big bridge fight scene increase
Peter hello Peter, I will explain the second
why he knows who Tom Holland's Peter Parker
is in this is the part of the movie that Sam
Raimi commented on he just said that he got
that it was beautiful that they brought Alfred
Molina's character back in talk a little bit
about the way they were changing the special
effects for his octopus arms say that when
they made Spider-Man two.
They use puppetry to do all of his arms using
a lot of digital effects to DH Alfred Molina
little bit because he is almost 20 years older's
they want him to look almost exactly like
he did during Spider-Man 2.
One of the more subtle Easter eggs are not
subtle Easter eggs for Tobey Maguire that
you probably also notice during this big bridge
fight scene is that when he standing on the
car and he gets her to put on the iron spider
suit after that scene where Doctor octopus
says hello Peter Tom Holland's Spider-Man
is wearing almost the exact same suit, the
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man war during his movies.
That's why a lot of people think that there's
some trickery going on in the seem like maybe
this really is a tom Holland.
Maybe this is a fake seen in section Tobey
Maguire standing here.
I don't totally think that's the case, but
I do believe that some of these scenes have
been fake just a little bit.
Then there's Willem Dafoe's Green goblin because
the goblin bombs and his cackle there also
a lot of people the claim that these are pictures
of him from the actual movie itself.
I don't know if that's true or not but the
great thing about Willem Dafoe is that if
you look at him now.
And you look at him during the events of the
original Spider-Man movies.
It doesn't look like he's aged a day.
Like he looks almost exactly the same.
Then there's Jamie Fox's electro he was announced
a long time ago and made all those post on
his Instagram account so we knew he was going
to be in the movie.
But now you can see his yellow lightning twice
during the trailer.
The reason why it's yellow is just because
they're making him look more comic book accurate
during this movie but is meant to be his version
of electro from the amazing Spider-Man two,
also during this particular electro scene.
You can see what looks like Sandman rising
up from the ground with a giant face forming
in the dust cloud here.
I also kind of think the black and gold suit
that you see Spider-Man wearing here in the
bottom corner the frame during this fight
is like the MCU version of the antishock suit
just based on the way it seems like he's using
it during these scenes.
They make perfect replica toys.
Like this hot toys, design, which gives us
a way better look at the actual students up
notice all the circuitry weaved around it
makes with what seems like Doctor Strange's
magical artifacts is gauntlets like he's wearing
Doctor Strange magic gauntlets this blue effect
is meant to represent him using magical energy
for shields and for his webbing like him creating
a shield that looks similar to the one Doctor
Strange used in Avengers infinity war.
But blue whatever's going on with his webbing
here.
It just seems like it's magic enhanced webbing
then the fifth sinister six character is the
less visible what seems like a lizard here
in this Doctor Strange dungeon seem like you
see a hand reach out and try to call him if
you tuneup the picture just a little bit it
does seem like a lizard hand trying to swipe
them in a separate scene when is running through
the fee shelter rips his mask off chasing
one of the villains down.
If you look at his chest, it looks like it's
got big claw marks in it.
Like lizard claw marks across the chest, there
was supposedly behind-the-scenes picture of
this basement see that more clearly highlighted
all the cells that leaked out.
I'm not gonna put in this video just for copyright
reasons Sony probably would take it down but
it just confirms what we all saw in the previous
trailers.
But basic timeline for the movie.
The way it seems like he goes down is the
first he comes to Doctor Strange 2 make the
one more day request.
Please make everyone forget them Spider-Man
that goes completely wrong with unintended
consequences bring the multiverse sinister
six villains from the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
movies in the Andrew Garfield Spider-Man movies
in at some point Doctor Strange is captures
the sinister six villains and contains them
in these magical prison cells where we get
to the bridge fight scene where it seems like
he's fighting multiple sinister six villains
like you have the Doctor octopus fight.
But you also have the goblin bombs clearly
they have to escape at some point we see Spider-Man
fighting Doctor Strange that magic box with
the special schedules on it the symbol on
the box is the same symbol of Agamotto the
pattern that you can see on the I have Agamotto
amulet, which is wearing again and the symbol
is also part of the sigil on all the sanctum's
in the window here they explained in the first
Doctor Strange movie that the sigil is part
of the enchantment that protects this Main
MCU reality in combination with the other
symbols it acts as a barrier a shield against
beings like dormammu or Shuma Gorath from
other dimensions the fact that it's on the
box in Spider-Man seems like he wants to open
the box makes it sound like the box contains
the key to these other universes in Spider-Man
thinks that for whatever reason opening it
will make everything go back to the way it
used to be, of course that probably only make
things worse.
It is he that the sinister six villains just
take advantage of that using that as an opportunity
to escape.
But even though we don't see him in the trailer
here.
Michael Keaton's vulture would be the sixth
OG member of the classic sinister six.
But one of the reasons why they're using so
many of them in this trailer even if they're
not all big characters in the movie.
Maybe some of them are just smaller cameos.
Is it was revealed that Sony is wanting to
do a new sinister six solo movie franchise
off by itself.
Like do Spider-Man sequels.
Like Spider-Man for but also separately do
sinister six movies you may remember they
tried to do the exact same thing during the
Andrew Garfield amazing Spider-Man era Andrew
Garfield himself said that would've been really
cool, they did have some cool plans that was
with the whole amazing Spider-Man to post
credit scene was meant to set up that they
were going to do the sinister six team in
a spinoff movie, but no on top of all these
Easter eggs are all kinds of theories that
Marvel is messing with the trailer footage
faking some scenes.
Like they did with the avengers infinity war
trailer and the avengers endgame trailers
to the people don't actually know what's going
on.
Like a lot of stuff in these trailers could
be totally fake.
But with that being said based on all the
new details it seems like were just getting
a little Andrew Garfield Spider-Man in the
tiniest smallest cameo scene from Tobey Maguire's
right now based on everyone hunting down Tobey
Maguire for pictures the past six months.
It seems like he's probably only can have
a very short scene.
Probably at the end of the movie and without
more evidence.
I do not think that were going to see him
wearing his Spider-Man costume.
Even though that would be really cool in not
withstanding all the recent Andrew Garfield
amazing Spider-Man supposedly eggs.
I think that at some point in the movie, we
will see him in his Spider-Man costume in
a more active role than Tobey Maguire Spider-Man,
so just be sure to temper your expectations
accordingly.
If you think you spotted any more Tobey Maguire
or Andrew Garfield Spider-Man references during
the trailer footage.
Just write a blown the comments Rick and get
a new trailer.
Pretty soon and in that trailer.
The pie be even more Easter eggs and references
to their Spider-Man movies in another's all
kinds of rumors about the venom let there
be carnage post credit scene, and Spider-Man
crossover the movies out on Thursday so I
will do my full post credit scene video.
Either Thursday night or Friday morning and
you want to wait that long to find out was
actually going on.
Yes, Tom Hardy was wearing a Spider-Man No
Way Home crew had in the only give those the
people who worked on the movie but is he that
somebody just gave him that he's not a huge
character in the movie.
Maybe maybe at best we have a small post credit
scene reference hinting at Spider-Man venom
crossover.
Eventually, but that's probably going to be
it for venom in this movie my full marvel
what if episode 8 video will post on Wednesday
just like normal.
It's for the version of Ultron winds up getting
all six infinity stones.
Everyone click here for my brand-new marvel
a turtles trailer video and click here for
my what if video all about the infinity gauntlet
version of Ultron.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next video!